Sir, what are you doing on Tuesday, ma'am,
Tuesday is a very good day, so
go to Hanuman ji's place and bring prasad. Will
you bring prasad or not? Sir, I will
bring it for everyone in the office, tell me ma'am and
bring it for the children too.  Do you give it? Yes, but
sir, Prasad will not suffice. Children
's exam is also coming and we will
have to do something for that too. Yaram, this is right, at least
bring something for the children and apart from
the Prasad, sir, definitely
keep it a surprise.  Isn't it released on Tuesday only on Tuesday, right so on Tuesday, please join us
on Infinity Channel, Ma'am and
I will together bring a surprise along with Prasad for all of you.
Okay, this is the state.